all right let's continue this
conversation by bringing in lieutenant
governor of texas dan patrick this
morning lieutenant governor great to
have you on the program
um
let's let's do this
i would love to hear you in your words
explain for anybody that might be
confused the purpose of sending illegal
immigrants to places like martha
vineyards chicago or new york
thanks will and good to be on with y'all
again so i've been you know this is
campaign season with the election coming
up and i've traveled i'm traveling to
130 cities around rural texas because
that's where the vote is to get out like
most states rural texas is very red
and everywhere i go the number one issue
they say to me is we have to secure the
border everywhere i've been to 35 cities
this week and not only that but they say
keep the buses going dan and the reason
we're sending the buses is
we do want to send a message
and
hopefully these
blue democrats and these cities and
these governors in these blue states
will put enough pressure on the
president to say mr president
you're obviously wrong the border is not
secure
and you need to help us stop this i
don't i don't care what crying they're
doing i'm crying their beer all day long
and the people of martha's vineyard what
a bunch of elitist hypocrites they are
and you know what what they've really
done is signal to us we need to send
more buses to places like hollywood or
bel air maybe barbara streisand she had
a great song in the 70s i think called
people you know people i need people
yeah we'll send her some people to her
street because she and the leftist
hollywood crowd and the and the elitist
on the east coast and other places
around america they support all these
policies oh no let everyone come in
we're a sanctuary city we love these
people and as soon as they actually get
off the bus suddenly they don't get away
from me get away from me we don't want
them in our neighborhood
right let them own what they support
they need to own up what they support
let them understand what our people are
dealing with especially in our border
towns where we are overrun every day
yeah i mean we i you know i said it on
the show earlier i was one of those
people that said oh this is just a stunt
um when governor abbott
i think it's been very effective i don't
think it's been more effective than on
martha's vineyard um because i think it
also exposed as you said the elitism
they like these you know brown people um
to probably work in their homes um but
not to actually be on their beautiful
island and so they got rid of them
quickly now my question to you is as
much as i like what i've seen in terms
of exposing this policy and bringing the
border to to some of the toniest
neighborhoods
i'm wondering why the state of texas
just never declared a state of emergency
so we could instead of you know feeling
helpless and this is all we can do is
send them to these other places
that they wouldn't normally go to
maybe we could stop it before it even
happens is am i being pollyanna-ish here
well you can't stop it before it happens
because the supreme court
already declared in the case with
arizona several years ago that the
federal government at least at this
point
has purview over the actual border but
when they don't do their job we are in a
state of emergency we are we are we have
to absorb
all the drugs that come in that kill our
kids we have to absorb all the people
that come in to over run towns like del
rio a population of 37 000 people that
have had 400 000 people in their sector
that would be like new york getting 10
times their population or 80 million
people
so we are we have been in a constant
state
of of
emergency because we have criminals
crossing the border terrorists crossing
the border and just
thousands of people uh coming into our
state every day i mean they're they're
crying that you know they've had 10 000
people that we've sent total on buses or
so since the beginning we have that
almost every day yeah and so i i have no
sympathy
for these elitist
leftists a liberal
democrats none whatsoever
i care about the american people and
until they feel the same pain texans are
feeling until they have to deal with the
same things we're dealing with it's not
until then that they'll put pressure on
their senators and their congressmen in
the democrat states to do something
about it mr governor this has to end
just to follow up on rachel's question
though i think we all agree that the
the the impact in the spotlight being
shown on this crisis by shipping illegal
immigrants to blue states and blue
cities is obviously effective but to
the goal being as you stated to pressure
the federal government into solving the
problem in lieu of that i think i think
i don't want to speak on your behalf but
there is an argument being made that as
for example the state of texas you could
declare an invasion that you would have
that constitutional power to begin to
deport illegal immigrants back to mexico
and if you then have a legal question
well then take that to the supreme court
and have that fight in front of the
supreme court i think that's what some
are wondering is that not a path to
actually solving the crisis that exists
at your border
yeah well so i've been saying this for a
long time many years i've been on fox
many times over the years i've been
calling this invasion for a long time
you know we are at a point right now
where mit did a study in 2016 and said
there were 25 to 30 million people here
illegally which matched up with the
numbers i had i've said this on i think
the show before
and that was back in 2016. there's not
11 million people that always you hear
it was 25 to 30 million seven years ago
so we're up at least with the mit study
we're up to 35 million now or more
that's remember apprehended
when i go around on my tour what i hear
from law enforcement all the time maybe
we catch one out of two or three so you
could double or triple that in addition
to that in joe biden's first year we had
two million that we apprehended the
first year two million this year that
we'll apprehend plus the guy aways we're
approaching 10 to 15 percent of the
total population in the united states of
america will be here illegally by the
time joe biden's first term is over you
have to understand this has been an
invasion for a long time this is a plan
by the left
they want to bring people in eventually
one day make sure they all have
citizenship so they can vote
uh people who are coming here illegally
as is a plan this is not an accident the
fact that they're angry about it is just
we're shining a light on it absolutely
and i hope that what we can do
is create another case we'll be back in
the legislative session in january that
we can get to the supreme court to
determine this one more time and maybe
this court will recognize that we do
have a right to protect our citizens on
the border right on the river let me
clarify that to be and we need we need
to be able to protect our people and
clarify on that fine point because you
mentioned
saying that it's invasion and we all
acknowledge and say that it is but is
there a formal declaration texas can or
should make does that happen from the
governor does that happen from the
legislature how does that supreme court
showdown happen if texas were to
formally say we're being invaded
the the the
look the governor will make that
decision but the the answer for the
legislature and i'm the president of the
senate the answer for the legislature is
to craft a bill
similar i don't want to say similar to
arizona but to make the case that we
have this
we have this legal right
to stand there and protect our
border look look this is not you know we
can we can send the buses to get
attention and and we can make comments
but let's let's look at what we're
dealing with we're dealing with fentanyl
coming over the border in such
amounts that it's the number one killer
of young people to 45. that's not a
laughing matter a joking matter that's
death families are experienced young
people dying because they got the wrong
pill that was sent over the border we
have criminals crossing the border ms-13
gang members crossing the border
terrorists crossing the border and the
only three people on the planet the only
three people on the planet that think
it's secure to the president the vice
president and the secretary of homeland
security and the mouthpiece for all of
them that shows up you know in the uh
at the white house press briefings every
day who doesn't ever tell the american
people the truth the only the only side
of the border that's secure is the other
side by the way understand this that no
one crosses that border unless they pay
their money to the cartels
they've the cartels have total control
of the border
they've secured their side we need to
secure our side and we want legislation
to be able to go up to the supreme court
to declare that once and for all so
there's no ambiguity whatsoever so this
has to this has to end so that there
would be a constitutional crisis then
i'm just curious if you pass that that
that bill in the tech and i'm a texan
you know
born and raised and uh and we uh
we want to see this solved like everyone
so i'm curious than the bill that you
plan crafting does that empower texas
dps or texas rangers to deport illegal
immigrants
well right now that's uh three months
away so let us write the bill but let me
assure you this
that we will write strong legislation
that makes sure there's no question that
we have a right to protect our citizens
so there's no argument um
the best way to win this
is to be sure that every state and
particularly the border states have a
right to defend our citizens to include
deportation to include deportation that
i mean
guys let me right guys let me let me uh
write a bill first let's not write it
here okay on the air on saturday morning
this takes let me tell you what when you
write a constitutional bill like we
wrote the heartbeat bill that survived
uh supreme court scrutiny and that bill
became law
writing legislation
that changes the constitution is very
serious business very serious business
it takes top scholars takes a lot of
thought and a lot of work not something
we just throw out here on a tv show and
say we're going to do this i'm serious
about this the legislators are serious
about this the people of texas are
serious about it the other thing i i'd
want to do we're spending by the way
guys to put this you know in perspective
all these all these whiny babies up in
these blue states oh this is such a
crisis we normally spend 400 million a
year on border security we're spending
over four billion dollars of texas
taxpayer money money we could spend on
health care on education on more roads
whatever it might be four billion
dollars a year we have our national
guard there on the border this is a
financial burden on us but most
importantly uh it's it's an invasion of
our state i've said it for a long time
i'm not shy about the word but we have
to do this the right way but i would i
will also
propose
uh that since we're spending so much
money i'd like to hire every border
patrol agent on the border every one of
them there's about eight thousand
we can afford to do it
hire them and make a new state border
guard so that joe biden doesn't have one
person left and by the way the border
patrol agents are dawn they're they're
heroes of my book they hate working for
this guy i think they love working for
texas and then and then let them look
around and find there's nobody there to
even do the job and we'll just say mr
president we'll take it over our
founding father you have to understand
this our founding fathers never believed
there'd be a president one day and
that's why the constitution is written
like it is they assume the president of
the united states would defend our
nation's borders they never imagined a
president like this would turn their
back on the american people they've
turned their back on the american people
they're dying because of it
and every place that we see
we're being overrun and just remember
this the people they sent them to a
military base right martha's vineyard
i've always asked this question and on
this show before exactly what is biden's
answer when we say where do these people
go where do they actually go how do they
live they move in with somebody they
can't we can't put a 15 year old in the
fourth grade they're two and three grade
levels behind where do they get their
health care services and emergency rooms
what do they do for working they don't
have a legal permit so they're just
they've been dumping people in america
for a long time a long time and now
texas is saying we're fighting back
we're going to send them to your
neighborhood and we're going to keep
those buses coming
until finally this this administration
wakes up and then we'll pass legislation
next session that will hopefully
get us to the supreme court where this
supreme court can rule that texas and
everyone else has a right to protect
their citizens and then we can do it
well we're doing the best we can now
under tough circumstances
no doubt they are tough circumstances
and you are doing the best you can and
we feel that i think the most
infuriating part is just how they've the
other side the democrats have wrapped
this up into compassion and i think that
the flights
i know and the flights i i believe have
exposed their hypocrisy um on a level
that um even even we were surprised by
so we we thank you for that um and can i
have one more point
people ask me all the time why aren't
you sending them to delaware we can't
find anybody crossing the border who
wants to go that's all i can do hey
lieutenant governor you said and just as
a point of clarification more buses
going um i'm curious can you tell us
where
no of course not what what i did say on
this show uh a month or so ago i did say
when it was just new
new york and washington i said if you're
a democrat governor or mayor you better
keep looking out your window because
more buses are coming to different
places if you are lieutenant i think i
was true lieutenant governor may i make
a suggestion to brooklyn to alexandria
ocasio-cortez's district and also to her
apartment she lives above a full of
whole foods um so i think that would be
a good spot because she was went to
texas to cry
um at a detention center and i never saw
anything out of her after the 50
migrants died you know basically um
burned alive in in that truck and now
she just put out a tweet saying that um
you guys are are you know this is
humanitarian crises and um you know
human rights and everything else because
of these uh trucks going to uh
buses going to martha's vineyard et
cetera so thank you well uh i think
that's uh i think it's a good name to
add to the list but i'd like to see
barbara streisand show up on her you
know on her curbside in her slippers and
and saying hey come on into my house
yeah here we go well it's ongoing
because we covered just this morning at
about 6 30 yet another bus from texas
right in front of the vice president's
residence in washington d.c so we'll
continue to track it lieutenant governor
thank you dan patrick thank you sir
thank you very much